موجه سابعه من الاحتجاج شهدتها فرنسا ضد
مساء الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
ترافقت الاحتجاجات مع اضراب شهدته قطاعات
ابرزها الطاقه والنقل حيث تم الغاء 20% من
الرحلات الجويه
يقوم بفعل كل شيء ضدنا وفي المقابل يعيش
حياته بكل رفاهيه الهدوء الذي حافظ عليه
المتظاهرون مع انطلاق الموكب الباريسي
سرعان ما تحول الى مواجهات مع الشرطه بضع
مئات من شبان اليسار العنيفين اشتبكوا مع
عناصر الشرطه عند محاولاتهم تحطيم واجهات
مصارف وشركات يقولون انها تمثل راس ماليه
مسؤوله عن ترد اوضاعهم الاشتباكات اوقعت
بعض الاصابات وسمحت للشرطه باجراء عمليات
اعتقال عنيفه وثقتها كاميرا العربيه
سريعا سيطرت الشرطه على الوضع وعاد الهدوء
الى تظاهره لم تقتصر المشاركه بها على
شريحه الموظفين او كبار السن بل ايضا شهدت
مشاركه شبابيه واسعه
مازلت صغير السن لكن هذا الاحتجاج يخص
الجميع انها فرصه تاريخيه لاثبات ان الشعب
في الشارع ولديه اهتمامات لا تتطابق مع
مدراء الشركات والمسؤولين ولديه النيه في
قلب الطاوله واستعاده السلطه حول العمل في
حصيله هذا اليوم اعلنت النقابات عن مشاركه
ثلاثمئه الف في الموكب الباريسي رقم قالت
الشرطه انه مبالغ به واعلنت انها احصت 48
الفا في باريس يراهن الرئيس
الفرنسي عامل الوقت لانهك الحركه
الاحتجاجيه لكن المتظاهرين يبدون
استعدادهم للذهاب بعيدا مهما كلف الامر
فدهوك العربيه باريس